hello and welcome to footnotes my name
is Matt Simon I'm here to recap the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today dude
dude dude dude dude dude dude dude dude
dude wire business took a look last week
at exactly why google+ is made up of
seventy percent dudes but where did this
word dude come from it's etymologies
unclear but it can be traced back to the
1880s in New York City what was used to
describe a very particular type of
well-dressed gentleman these dudes were
sort of American equivalent of the
British dandy who dressed ostentatiously
in order to give an air of affluence but
these American dudes took it one step
further than a dandies they would
actually have competitions among
themselves to see who could change
outfits the most in a single day and the
reigning king among them was one Barry
wall shown here doing his best
impression of a bell this king of dudes
got his title by winning a wager that
said he couldn't change outfits 40 times
between breakfast and dinner he did so
majestically of course which is amazing
to me because I have not owned 40
changes of clothes in the last decade
apparently back in the eighteen hundreds
Cowboys thought that every man from the
city was a dude hence the dude ranch
which caters specifically to city
slickers the term dude moved into surfer
culture and it's today so ubiquitous
that for some reason my dentist calls me
dude up next copyright trolls blast week
threat level reported on right Haven a
copyright troll that went around suing
websites that were posting newspaper
articles before going to funked in a
flame of glory last year so copyright
roll is a firm that Sue's aggressively
in order to monetize its copyrights and
the word troll works two ways here as a
noun it's about being a monster as a
verb it's about trolling to fish by
dragging baited lines behind a boat now
the copyright roll is a cousin of the
patent troll which believe it or not was
caught
film in 1994 for the very first time in
the uncreated Lee titled patent video
put out by the equally uncreated Lee
titled intellectual property videos LLC
a troll under a bridge demands money
from a boat I'd man this video was
distributed to universities and
corporations in the federal government
thus ensuring the proliferation of the
term the patent troll in the video is
asking for money I don't think is
exactly in keeping with traditional
Scandinavian folklore on account of
trolls not exactly subscribing to the
decidedly human idea of currency
exchange and again I think they had bow
ties back then either the king of the
dudes would have hated
you